welcome back we've had some breaking
news in the last few moments which is
that we've had a verdict from the
coroner in the case of the death of the
teenager Molly Russell we can go live
now to our correspondent Katie Spencer
who is at North London coroners Court
Katie
giving
inclusions in
we know since Molly died in 2017 her
family have campaigned actively in
response to what they discovered after
her death the amount of content that
she's been viewing in relation to
self-harm and suicide that they've
firmly believed that what she saw on the
social media contributed to her death
that the coroner in this case Andrew
Walker he has been delivering his
findings of fact and his conclusions in
this case and the conclusion he he's
come to is that we know Molly was
suffering from a depressive illness the
sites that she was viewing were not safe
she had access to images and text
relating to self-harm and suicide and
what he believes is the algorithms and
he heard in the last week from expert
testimonies saying that these algorithms
certainly were feeding Molly without her
requesting it very very negative images
of self-harm and suicide and she was
having these binge periods where she was
to be looking online at these images and
that was certainly having a real
negative effect on her her mental health
it was romanticizing the the idea of her
taking her own life some of it was
encouraging her to isolate herself away
what the coroner Andrew Walker said is
there was no counterbalance of normality
here and he believes that that likely
contributed to her death in a more than
minimal way is what he said in court he
said bear in mind the fact that these
sites essentially normalized her
condition what she was going through
this depressive state it portrayed
suicide the condition as something that
she wasn't going to be able to recover
from and given that the coroner has said
that he doesn't feel that it is safe
actually in this case to record a
verdict of suicide instead he has said
that she died as an act of self-harm
while suffering from depression and the
negative effects of uh of online content
and viewing that and we do believe that
actually the family will be at some
point in in the next few minutes
possibly in the next half an hour be
coming out and addressing us out the
front of Court here this of course has
been something that they have campaigned
for for quite a while they want those
social media companies involved to take
responsibility for the content that she
was viewing she was only 13 and 14 when
she joined Instagram and was viewing
this very dark material painting at an
incredibly Bleak world but I do think
really the fact that this verdict has
been recorded the way that it's been
recorded by the coroner here is
particularly particularly telling in
this case and could likely be a
watershed moment in terms of how these
social media companies go forward and
having to really take responsibility for
the content that they're feeding to to
younger users certainly